[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie as promised
new Captain Marvel video because it
sounds like we have a confirmed date for
the actual trailer in its way earlier
than I expected but it's right after
another big Disney trailer is dropping
for Mary Poppins so I'll explain what's
going on and a little bit more about
Star Wars so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get that
trailer video next week I'll explain
giveaway stuff at the end of the video -
that's still going on but the important
details first brie Larson is supposed to
guest star on Good Morning America
Tuesday morning
now they record at the ass crack of dawn
so it is gonna be super early if they're
dropping footage now the reason why
people think that the trailer is
dropping is is because that's the only
reason why people like pre Larson go on
Good Morning America so that they can
hit that really wide family middle aged
audience that don't keep up with comic
book stuff Good Morning America is like
the TV show that your parents in your
grandparents watch so you will be
forgiven if you have absolutely no idea
what's going on with that all you need
to know is that Good Morning America is
owned by ABC ABC is the television
network that's owned by Disney so Disney
sends a lot of its stars to Good Morning
America to hawk it swears so you get the
idea they spent a lot of time promoting
infinity war on Good Morning America so
you get a lot of really weird clips with
them doing things that have absolutely
nothing to do with comic books but still
telling people about the movie epic the
charity event called Marvel Universe
unites and involves action figures so
come on let's go check them out come on
[Applause]
with me I think it's one of those
end-of-the-summer things where Disney's
reminding people because on Monday
they're supposed to be dropping another
Mary Poppins trailer so Disney is just
pretty emptying New York comic-con which
is happening the first week in October
it's again everybody really hyped up
Plus Batman Day in that DC streaming
service is launching this weekend so
they might also be throwing some Marvel
stuff out there just to get people hyped
up but I think they had always planned
on dropping this Captain Marvel footage
relatively soon it's probably only gonna
be a couple minutes long maybe a little
bit shorter it'll just introduce you to
the concept of Captain Marvel what she
can do with the tone of the movie is
remember it's during the 90s so it would
not be surprised if they score the
trailer with some funny 90s music
speaking of funny Clark Gregg was
talking about Coulson during the Captain
Marvel movie he said that he's basically
a brand new agent he's obsessed with MC
Hammer and Nick Fury can't stand him so
I just love the idea of Clark Gregg you
know who's like mr. Captain America
during the first Avengers film I watched
you while you slept try to get cap to
sign all of his Captain America baseball
cards being obsessed with MC Hammer back
in the 90s so it sounds like it's gonna
be classic Coulson where he's a balance
of really funny but also really badass
at the same time they usually give him
some moment where he went up to one of
the villains so don't be surprised if
they replicate that moment with Loki at
the end of Avengers only Coulson isn't
dying while this is happening move away
please I like this
we started working on the prototype
after you sent the destroyer even I
don't know what it does we also got
details on some of the members of Star
Force here so just quick breakdown a lot
of you might recognize Jemma Chan from
crazy rich Asians she's playing Minerva
even though she's a villain in the
comics she's playing a crease sniper
during this but because they already
explained the plot of Star Force at the
beginning of the movie is that they're
trying to rescue someone on another
planet
Captain Marvel gets called away by Jude
Law so in the way that all these big
Marvel movies open with an action scene
the movies gonna open on the action of
what they're doing in this big rescue
force she'll be wearing that green
version of the costume before she comes
back
so her on planet earth here in this
picture in the classic Captain Marvel
colors
that's when she comes back for Secret
Invasion stuff but you kind of get the
idea is that some of the members of this
group are evil in the future or they're
evil in the comics so you do kind of
wonder how they're gonna use them
Korath from guardians of the galaxy is
in the movie just a younger version of
him he's an underling of Ronan's during
the guardians of the galaxy movie so you
have to assume a similar chain of
command like even though this is Jude
Law's group even though he they haven't
confirmed him as marbella we'll call it
Marvel leading the team Ronin is
probably his chief lieutenant because
he'd be the second most powerful person
then everyone else is serving under them
so Korath in the comics was a geneticist
I wouldn't be surprised if they try to
do a little bit more with his character
I think that's the idea that they bring
them back like look we used you as
villains during guardians of the galaxy
we didn't give you a lot of backstory
and you're some of the examples that
people provide when they talk about bad
Marvel villains so we redeem your
characters by broadening their backstory
into giving you so much more to do and
making you that much more complex this
is Atlas and bran char so atlas as in
Captain atlas who led Star Force in the
comics but obviously they're changing a
little bit of that for the movie because
Jude Law's Marvel is leading the team so
it seems like Captain atlas and bran
char are just foot soldiers or
infantrymen just badasses that are part
of the team the funny thing about these
characters in the comics is is that the
original Star Force plot that I talked
about during my Captain Marvel teaser
video is is that they were basically
trying to blow up the Kree homeworld
captain atlas was a staunch loyalist
didn't care what they were doing was
wrong so the supreme intelligence gave
him instructions he promptly activated
his self-destruct device killing himself
so I am just expecting them to do
something totally different with this
version of the character he looks
freaking huge so he is probably just
gonna be used for a little bit of comedy
like the Hulk of the group it's supposed
to be a big 90s action movies so I'm
just expecting those type of tropes the
other guy bran char was not a member of
Star Force in the comics but he was
noted for breaking a version of Captain
America's shield that's like pretty much
the only big thing that he's ever done
in the comics and I think we're all
pretty much on the same page that Jude
Law is playing a version of Marvel
Walter Lawson which is what variety
announced him as when he was initially
cast last November it's been almost a
year since that's happened nobody else
has said anything different about who
he's playing in the way Jude Law himself
describes the character makes him sound
like Marvel he's a mentor to Carol
Danvers he has a very close relationship
with her the other members of Star Force
are kind of resentful of her
relationship with the boss man and he
has this vast cosmic understanding that
will help her learn how to use her
abilities so all the clues are just
pointing towards him being that original
Captain Marvel from the comics and him
might die during the course of the film
he's kind of like the Steve Trevor of
this movie no idea how close they'll be
to what they did was Steve Trevor during
Wonder Woman if they kill him off
because he did die after he passed the
torch in the comics after she got her
powers in the comics they had a
relationship he mentored her for a while
then he died from cancer of all things
and that she just went on to become
Captain Marvel eventually many many
years later but if they're bringing
Steve Trevor back and that Wonder Woman
sequel you just have no idea what
they're gonna do with some of these
characters only that because this is
taking place 20 years in the past so
much is gonna happen between now and
then so I wouldn't be surprised if they
have something at the end of the movie
that lets you know what happened to that
missing 20 years why she wasn't around
but it will probably be the page that
she gets from Nick Fury in the future
there are a lot of theories about how
that's gonna happen like if it's just
gonna be her powers that keep her
looking young the same way that the
Super Soldier serum makes Captain
America age vastly slower than everyone
else but as for actual trailer footage
because this is the first time we've
ever
a live-action version of the character
they're gonna spend a lot of energy and
a lot of promos just explaining the
concepts of who she is what the tone of
the movie is in how this is going to be
different from guardians of the galaxy
but they don't want to feel like the
exact same movie even though there's a
lot of comedy in it just like the
guardians franchise it's gonna be in a
different part of space in a different
era and it's meant to feel like a big
90s action film so like oh rewatch
Terminator 2 in the way they use comedy
in that film it's gonna be a little bit
like that it is gonna be so funny though
if we get to Tuesday and everybody on
the internet is talking about this
trailer and it doesn't drop people are
going to be pissed
so if you do have any other requests for
Captain Marvel videos just leave them in
the comments below we're still doing
that spider-man ps4 giveaway so I'll
keep doing that in all my Marvel videos
for the next couple of weeks
congratulations Ian Hughes you're the
winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my youtube
channel so I can get your details click
here for brand new Avengers 4 and click
here for that other Captain Marvel
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]